Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a biweekly podcast from the American Psychological Association. I'm your host, Caitlin Luna. Suicide rates in the U.S. climbed in all but one state from 1999 to 2016, according to a CDC report issued in June 2018. This alarming report and notable celebrity suicide deaths like Anthony Bourdain and Kate Spade have pushed this topic further into the next. national spotlight. In this episode, we'll be exploring the factors that cause people to die from suicide, the effects of past trauma on mental health, and how psychologists can successfully treat suicidal patients. Our guest is Dr. Samuel Knapp, a licensed psychologist in Pennsylvania who has worked in rural community mental health centers delivering psychotherapy and crisis intervention services.
欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会推出的双周播客。我是主持人凯特琳·卢纳。根据美国疾病控制与预防中心（CDC）2018年6月发布的一份报告，1999年至2016年间，美国除一个州外，其他所有州的自杀率均有所上升。这份令人震惊的报告，加上安东尼·波登和凯特·丝蓓等名人的自杀离世，将这一话题推向了全国关注的焦点。在本期节目中，我们将探讨导致人们自杀的因素、过往创伤对心理健康的影响，以及心理学家如何成功治疗有自杀倾向的患者。我们的嘉宾是塞缪尔·纳普博士，他是一位在宾夕法尼亚州执业的心理学家，曾在农村社区心理健康中心从事心理治疗和危机干预服务。
He's the author of the forthcoming book, Suicide Prevention, an ethically and scientifically informed approach that will be published by APA in August. Suicide is also the cover story for the July-August issue of the Monitor on Psychology, APA's magazine for members that covers science, education, psychology practice, and more. Welcome, Dr. Knapp. Thank you. My first question for you is, why do people die from suicide? Suicide is multi-determined, meaning that many factors can be involved, but we have identified some common factors that reappear over and over again. One of the major ones is a lack of social connections so that people perceive themselves as unwanted or as a burden to others.
他是即将出版的新书《自杀预防：一种基于伦理和科学的方法》的作者，该书将于8月由美国心理学会（APA）出版。自杀也是《心理学监测》7月/8月刊的封面故事，这是APA为会员提供的杂志，涵盖科学、教育、心理学实践等内容。欢迎您，纳普博士。谢谢。我的第一个问题是，人们为什么会自杀？自杀是由多种因素决定的，这意味着许多因素都可能参与其中，但我们已经确定了一些反复出现的共同因素。其中一个主要因素是缺乏社会联系，导致人们认为自己是不受欢迎的，或者是他人的负担。
In fact, Dr. Thomas Joyner, a noted suicidologist, has used the term perceived burdensomeness to describe that sense of being a burden on others. And as a society, it appears that we are becoming more disconnected from each other, and that may be a factor in the increase in the suicide rates. But the immediate cause might be a disruption of a social relationship, loss of a job, financial distress, some kind of humiliation. But usually there's a loss of social concern. connecting us as well.
事实上，著名的自杀学专家托马斯·乔伊纳博士曾用“感知到的负担感”这一术语来描述那种成为他人负担的感觉。作为一个社会，我们似乎正变得越来越疏离，这可能是自杀率上升的一个因素。但直接原因可能是社会关系的破裂、失业、经济困境或某种羞辱。但通常情况下，我们也失去了将我们联系在一起的社会关怀。
You mentioned Dr. Thomas Joyner. He and other psychologists developed the interpersonal theory of suicide. Can you explain what that theory is? It's a very helpful theory and that it on its surface is very simple, but it's actually very useful and that suicide is caused by both a desire to die and the capability of killing oneself. And the desire to die is usually associated with thwarted belongingness, not being part of a valued social group or perceived burdensomeness. And then you have the second step, which is the acquired capability. That means a person has overcome the normal habituation, the normal inhibitions
您提到了托马斯·乔伊纳博士。他和其心理学家同行共同开发了“自杀人际理论”。您能解释一下这个理论吗？这是一个非常有用的理论，表面上看很简单，但实际上非常实用。该理论认为，自杀是由“死亡欲望”和“自杀能力”共同导致的。死亡欲望通常与“归属感缺失”（即无法融入有价值的社会群体）或“感知到的负担感”有关。然后是第二步，即“习得性能力”。这意味着一个人已经克服了正常的习惯化，克服了正常的抑制。
against harming oneself. We have very strong self-preservation instinct. And it takes a lot for people to overcome that. And it usually occurs when people have become habituated to pain and suffering or they lose their fear of death. There's other, it's called an ideation to action theory. And there's other ideation to action theories. And they overlap a great deal. But all of them look at the unique role that acquired capability has and leading a person to die from suicide. And what do you think the factors are behind that steep rise in suicide deaths around the U.S.
即对伤害自己的抑制。我们有非常强烈的自我保护本能。人们需要付出很多努力才能克服这一点。这通常发生在人们已经习惯了痛苦和折磨，或者失去了对死亡的恐惧之后。这被称为“意念到行动理论”。还有其他类似的意念到行动理论，它们之间有很大的重叠。但所有这些理论都关注“习得性能力”在导致一个人自杀过程中的独特作用。您认为美国自杀死亡人数急剧上升背后的因素是什么？
That was noted by the CDC? Well, I think it's the increased lack of social connectedness that we have in society. Now, suicide is also multi-determined, I mentioned. And we have to realize, too, that even though the nation itself is prosperous, there are many areas of the country and many professions where people are, struggling financially. You know, farmers losing their family farms, a great sense of loss, a great sense of anger itself because they weren't able to make it. And so those are, those are factors as well. We have very high incarceration rate in the United States. And incarceration is often a life event that causes some people to attempt suicide.
CDC报告中提到了这一点。我认为这是社会中社会联系日益缺乏所致。现在，我提到过自杀是由多种因素决定的。我们还必须意识到，尽管国家本身很繁荣，但国内许多地区和许多行业的人们都在为经济问题而挣扎。你知道，农民失去了家庭农场，会产生巨大的失落感，以及因为无法维持生计而产生的强烈愤怒。所以这些也是因素。美国有非常高的监禁率。而监禁往往是一个导致某些人尝试自杀的生活事件。
And that report did note that in some states, especially North Dakota, the suicide rate went up significantly during that time period. And Montana had the highest per capita rate in that, I believe, between 2014 and 2016. Does that speak to some of the issues going on in rural areas, which you've had experience with? Yes. In fact, some people have referred to the, they call the geographical suicide belt, which is, you know, Western states, rural states, having an increased rate to suicide. Now, there's many factors for this one, which is that some of these states have a higher proportion of older adults, and older adults do die from suicide more frequently than younger people.
那份报告确实指出，在一些州，特别是北达科他州，自杀率在那段时间显著上升。我相信在2014年至2016年间，蒙大拿州的人均自杀率最高。这是否反映了您曾有过相关经验的农村地区所存在的一些问题？是的。事实上，有些人称之为“地理自杀带”，即西部各州、农村各州，自杀率较高。这有很多因素，其中之一是这些州的老年人比例较高，而老年人自杀的频率确实比年轻人高。
They have a greater access to guns, because it's very common for the average household to have a gun. they have a lack of adequate health care services in many of those areas. There's longer distances between people, greater risk of social isolation, younger people moving out, family members moving out. So you have all those factors that appear to occur. There's nothing inherent about living in Montana that increases one's risk of suicide. It's just that people in Montana are more likely to have these high risk. risk factors that we know about.
他们更容易获得枪支，因为普通家庭拥有枪支非常普遍。在许多这些地区，他们缺乏足够的医疗保健服务。人与人之间的距离更远，社会孤立的风险更大，年轻人搬走，家庭成员搬走。所以所有这些因素似乎都出现了。居住在蒙大拿州本身并没有什么内在因素会增加一个人的自杀风险。只是蒙大拿州的人更有可能具备我们所知的这些高风险因素。
And one very interesting thing in that report was that more than half of people who died by suicide did not have a diagnosed or known mental health condition at the time of death. So what does that tell us? That whole issue is controversial. You know, the relationship between a diagnosed mental illness and a suicide attempt. Now, Thomas Joyner, whom I mentioned before, did a study where he looked, to the medical records of people, and even if they didn't have a diagnosed mental illness, a lot of them appeared to have symptoms that were noted in the medical record, suggesting that
报告中一个非常有趣的发现是，超过一半的自杀身亡者在死亡时并没有被诊断出或已知的心理健康状况。这告诉了我们什么？整个问题存在争议。你知道，诊断出的精神疾病与自杀企图之间的关系。我之前提到的托马斯·乔伊纳做过一项研究，他查看了人们的医疗记录，即使他们没有被诊断出精神疾病，许多人似乎也有医疗记录中提到的症状，这表明
perhaps they really did have a mental illness that was not diagnosed, or maybe they were in great distress, but didn't meet a formal definition of mental illness. So I suspect that the rate of emotional turmoil or mental illness is probably higher, far higher than with the CDC. suggested. There's also been some very useful research from Palo Alto University with Dr. Joyce Chu, who looked at suicide among Asian Americans. And she found that the rate of mental illness, instead of being 90% higher, as most studies find, was about, I think, if I recall correctly, about 66%. So she's suggesting that mental illness is less a factor in Asian American suicides. But then I wonder if some of these Asian-Americans didn't have cultural variations
也许他们确实患有未被诊断的精神疾病，或者他们处于极度痛苦中，但不符合精神疾病的正式定义。所以我怀疑情绪困扰或精神疾病的发生率可能比CDC建议的要高得多。帕洛阿尔托大学的乔伊斯·楚博士也进行了一些非常有用的研究，她研究了亚裔美国人的自杀问题。她发现精神疾病的比例并不是大多数研究发现的90%以上，如果我没记错的话，大约是66%。所以她认为精神疾病在亚裔美国人自杀中的因素较小。但我怀疑其中一些亚裔美国人是否有一些文化变异
of distress that aren't picked up in the usual diagnostic nomenclature that based primarily on Western populations. Now, this is just speculation on my part. But the CDC finding of less and half of people with diagnosed mental illness. I think we need to put that in perspective and say that might say more about our diagnostic system than about suicide itself, which is almost always linked to great emotional turmoil, a diagnosable mental illness, or a cultural variation of a mental illness. So there's definitely a lot more involved in this than just simply saying that these people didn't have...
的痛苦，而这些痛苦并没有被主要基于西方人群的常规诊断命名法所捕捉到。现在，这只是我个人的推测。但CDC关于不到一半的人被诊断出患有精神疾病的发现，我认为我们需要将其放在一个视角下看待，这可能更多地说明了我们的诊断系统，而不是自杀本身，自杀几乎总是与巨大的情绪困扰、可诊断的精神疾病或精神疾病的文化变异有关。所以这绝对不仅仅是说这些人没有……
That's right. Yeah. Yeah, far more than that. And going back to what you're talking about about older people, there was an investigation by Kaiser Health News and PBS News Hour that found that older Americans are quietly killing themselves in nursing homes, assisted living centers, and adult care homes. What are your thoughts about that report? Well, there is what we call passive suicidal ideation. Now, going back to the interpersonal theory, remember, there was the desire to die and then the capability. of dying. And some of the people in nursing homes may have a desire to die, but because they're in a
没错。是的，远不止于此。回到您谈到的关于老年人的话题，凯撒健康新闻和PBS新闻一小时进行了一项调查，发现美国老年人正在疗养院、辅助生活中心和成人护理院中悄悄自杀。您对那份报告有什么看法？嗯，有一种我们称之为“被动自杀意念”。现在，回到人际理论，记住，有“死亡欲望”和“死亡能力”。疗养院里的一些人可能有死亡欲望，但因为他们处于一个
restricted environment, they don't have the capability, or maybe they don't have, maybe they haven't become sufficiently habituated to pain and suffering that they've overcome their inhibitions against actually killing themselves. But there is such a thing as a past of suicidal ideation. People just wish that God would take them away and wish that they didn't have to live anymore even though they can't actively take steps to kill themselves. And people in nursing homes are more likely to have some of the risk factors associated with suicide, such as a comorbid mental illness, a comorbid physical illness, chronic pain,
受限的环境中，他们没有能力，或者也许他们没有，也许他们还没有习惯于痛苦和折磨，以至于他们克服了对自己进行自杀的抑制。但确实存在“被动自杀意念”这种东西。人们只是希望上帝能带走他们，希望他们不必再活下去，即使他们不能主动采取措施自杀。疗养院里的人更有可能具备一些与自杀相关的风险因素，例如共病精神疾病、共病身体疾病、慢性疼痛、
restriction in their activities of daily living, loss of connection with other people. In fact, one study found that when suicides do occur, nursing homes. It very often occurs when a loved one has been transferred out of a nursing home, and so a big social connection has been lost. Also, a very interesting perspective by psychologist Kim Van Orden talked about the role of the ages of might play in this, which is something I hadn't thought about, which I probably should think about because I'm an old man, but people get put into an age role. You're expected, your expectations people, they can't do this stuff or they're not interested
日常生活活动受限、与他人失去联系。事实上，一项研究发现，当自杀发生时，疗养院。这通常发生在亲人被转出疗养院时，因此失去了一个重要的社会联系。此外，心理学家金·范·奥登的一个非常有趣的观点谈到了年龄角色在其中可能扮演的角色，这是我之前没有想到的，我可能应该考虑一下，因为我是一个老人，但人们被置于一个年龄角色中。你被期望，人们对你的期望，他们做不了这些事，或者他们对事情不感兴趣
in things. They just need to sit in a corner. And maybe that's a factor too that I had not thought about before. You've spoken a lot about the importance of social connections. And I think that might apply in this case. I want to get your thoughts on it. But more than a million children and teens in the U.S. were admitted to the emergency room for suicidal thoughts or suicidal attempts, an amount that doubled
。他们只需要坐在角落里。也许这也是我之前没有想到的一个因素。您谈了很多关于社会联系的重要性。我认为这可能适用于这种情况。我想听听您的想法。但是，根据《美国医学会杂志·儿科》的数据，美国有超过一百万的儿童和青少年因自杀念头或自杀企图被送进急诊室，这一数字在2007年至2015年间翻了一番。您对为什么会发生这种情况有什么见解吗？这与您谈到的社会联系有关吗？我认为是的。而且还有一些推测，不仅仅是推测，还有一些关于智能手机、社交媒体作用的研究。有些人认为，并不是智能手机本身导致人们自杀风险增加，而是它干扰了人们正常的、健康的、直接的人际接触。所以拥有智能手机对青少年来说本身并不坏，但如果它阻止他们参与真正健康的体验，它就会变得有害。
between 2007 and 2015, according to JAMA pediatrics. Do you have any insights on why this is happening? Is it related to that social connection that you're talking about for? I think it is. And there's also been some speculation on, not more than speculation, some research on the role of smartphones, social media. And some people are thinking that it isn't the smartphones per se that's leading people to increase the risk of suicide, but that it interferes with normal, healthy, direct interpersonal contact that people have. And so having a smartphone is intrinsically bad for a teenager, but it becomes bad if it keeps them from engaging in experiences that are really healthy.
有益且美好。但是是的，缺乏联系是青少年面临的一个非常严重的问题。这是一个需要解决的社会性问题。是的，我今年早些时候做了一个关于孤独的播客，非常引人入胜。我谈了很多关于社会联系对我们身心健康的重要性。那是一次非常好的对话。回到您刚才提到的，当我们谈论其他一些农村州时，可能会出现一些问题，但我认为这是一个更全国性的问题。但国家经济研究局在4月下旬发布了一份论文，发现当一个州的最低工资提高，或者当该州为工薪家庭提供良好的税收抵免时
helpful and good. But yes, disconnectiveness is it's a very serious problem with adolescence. It's a society-wide problem that needs to be addressed. Yeah, I did a recent podcast earlier this year about loneliness, which is very fascinating. I talked a lot about the importance of social connections for our physical and mental well-being. It was very good, very good conversation. And going back, you also mentioned too when we were talking about some of the other rural states, some issues that might come into play there, but I think this is more of a national issue. But the National Bureau of Economic Research released a paper in late April that found that when the minimum wage in a state increased or when the state offered good tax credits
，自杀率就会下降。您对此有何看法？这很有道理。你失去了收入。你有经济不安全感，男性被社会化为养家糊口的角色，如果他们做不到这一点，这就是巨大的羞辱来源。所以这对我来说很有道理。随着收入不平等加剧，随着经济不安全感增加，那些容易自杀的人，这是一种额外的负担。美国自杀率最高的时期之一是在20世纪90年代初。
for working families, the suicide rate decreased. What do you think about that? It makes sense. You have the loss of income. You have financial insecurity, males are socialized into a breadwinning role, and if they fail to do that, it's a source of great humiliation. So that makes a lot of sense to me. As income inequality rises, as financial insecurity increases, people who are vulnerable to suicide, that's an added burden. One of the greatest spikes in suicide in the United States was in the early 9th.
1930年代，大萧条初期。我的意思是，这是经济不安全对自杀率影响的典型例子。我想谈谈创伤的持久影响，特别是与最近三起备受瞩目的自杀事件有关的。其中之一是杰里米·里士满，他的女儿在桑迪胡克小学枪击案中遇害，另外两名是帕克兰学校枪击案的幸存者。您能解释一下创伤经历对一个人心理健康的持久影响吗？是的，这与自杀的人际理论有关。
1930s during the early years of the Great Depression. And I mean, that's a typical example of the impact of economic insecurity on suicide rates. I want to talk a bit about the lasting impact of trauma, specifically in relation to three recent high-profile suicides. One of those was Jeremy Richmond, whose daughter was killed at Sandy Hook, and then two Parkland school shooting survivors. Can you explain the lasting impact of a traumatic experience on a person's mental health? Yes, well, this relates to the interpersonal theory of suicide.
正如我提到的，“习得性能力”是托马斯·乔伊纳确定的与自杀企图相关的因素之一。当人们接触到暴力、习惯于痛苦并失去对死亡的恐惧时，就会产生习得性能力。这解释了为什么。你看看统计上较高的自杀率，发现它们发生在医生、性工作者、警察、凶杀案侦探等群体中，你会想，这些群体有什么共同点？他们确实有一个共同点，那就是接触到痛苦和折磨。所以，在人们拥有这些之后。现在，失去对暴力、痛苦的恐惧并不一定是坏事，因为你不想让一个如此害怕痛苦的医生说她不能很好地完成工作。或者一个如此害怕痛苦的警察在需要行动时变得瘫痪。
And as I mentioned, acquired capability is one of the factors that Thomas Joyner has identified as related to a suicide attempt. And the acquired capability occurs when people have had exposure to violence, they become habituated to suffering, and they lose their fear. of death. And this explains why. You look at statistically higher rates of suicide, and they find that they occur among people who are physicians, people who are sex workers, police officers, homicide detectives, and you think, well, what do all these groups have in common? And one thing that they do have in common is exposure to pain and suffering. And so, in the And people have that. Now, losing your fear of violence, fear of suffering isn't necessarily bad because you don't want to have a physician who's so afraid of suffering that says she can't do her job well. Or a police officer who's so afraid of suffering that she becomes paralyzed in a time when action is needed.
但当它与死亡欲望结合时，它就成为自杀企图的一个因素。所以我们有这些人，我的意思是，我不认识他们。我唯一知道的是，非常简短的事情是他们接触过创伤和暴力。但接触过创伤和暴力的人确实增加了发展出那种自杀的习得性能力的风险。你在虐待儿童的受害者身上也能发现这一点。现在，大多数虐待儿童的受害者，尽管经历了巨大的痛苦，但他们可以为自己开创美好的生活。但从统计学上讲，如果他们曾是童年暴力的受害者，他们自杀身亡的比例更高。所以你确实创造了这种
but when it's combined with the desire to die, then it becomes a factor in a suicide attempt. So we have people, these people, I mean, I don't know them. I don't, only thing I know is, you know, the very brief thing is that they've been exposed to trauma and violence. But people who are exposed to trauma and violence do have an increased risk of developing that acquired capability to kill themselves. You find this with child abuse victims too. Now, most of the people who are victims of child abuse will go on and despite the great pain involved, they can carve out good lives for themselves. But statistically, there are at a higher rate to die from suicide if they've been a victim of childhood violence. So you do create this
对痛苦和折磨的习惯化，这确实增加了人们的风险。而且因为这些，我提到的人不得不经历他们生活中这些令人难以置信的创伤性事件。是的。是的，我想有一件事确实让我对这些故事感到震惊，那就是多年之后。所以，特别是对于桑迪胡克受害者的父亲，他非常积极地参与研究人们为什么会实施暴力。
habituation of pain and suffering that does increase the risk to people. And because these, the people I mentioned had to experience these incredibly traumatic events in their lives. Yes. Yeah, I think that one thing that was really, I guess, struck me about those stories was how many years it was later. So, especially for the father of the Sandy Hook victim, and he was very actively involved in research into why people commit violence.
然而多年后，他还是自杀了。这告诉了我们关于创伤如何持续很长时间的什么信息？这是否说明了你可能感觉良好几年，但后来可能会有一个点，让你觉得无法承受，于是决定采取这种行动？嗯，这是一个因素。希望大多数经历创伤的人能够得到一些帮助，能够把创伤抛在脑后。但是，正如这些案例所说明的那样，并非总是如此。
And yet years later, he did die by suicide. What does this tell us about how trauma can last for a long period of time? Does this say anything more about how you might feel fine for several years, but then there could be a point where it gets to be too much and you decide to take this action? Well, it is a factor. and hopefully most people experiencing trauma will be able to get some help, be able to put the trauma in the back of their lives. But, you know, not always, as these cases illustrate.
我还想谈谈，自杀会聚集在一起吗？我知道这可能是一个非常有争议的话题。最近刚有一篇文章，一堆新闻报道发布，关于电视剧《十三个原因》播出后青少年自杀死亡人数的增加。许多文章在建立两者之间的联系时都很谨慎，但他们确实注意到该剧播出后自杀死亡人数有所增加。我们以前也见过这种情况，在名人去世后。有时我听说名人去世后自杀率确实会上升。两者之间有联系吗？它们会聚集在一起吗？
And I want to talk about, too, about do suicides cluster together? I know this can be a very controversial topic. And there was just an article, a bunch of news stories. released recently about the increase in suicide deaths among teens after the airing of the show 13 reasons why. And many of the articles were cautious on making a link between that, but they did note an increase in suicide deaths after that show aired. And we've seen this before about after a celebrity dies. Sometimes I've heard that the rate of suicide does increase after that. Is there a connection and do they cluster together?
嗯，我们有两件事在发生。一个是“传染”，另一个是“聚集”。是的，您能解释一下每一个是什么吗？当然。所以，在名人自杀身亡后，会有大量的宣传。许多州已经对这种死亡对自杀率的影响进行了研究。这很难研究，因为自杀率存在自然波动。在春季、秋季，自杀率往往会上升。
Well, we have two things going on. One is called contagion and the other is called cluster. Yeah, can you explain what each one is? Sure. So after the death of a celebrity by suicide, there's a great deal of publicity to it. And many states have been done on the impact of this death upon suicide rates. And it's very hard to research because there are natural variations in suicide rates. During the spring, during the fall, suicide rates tend to increase.
所以如果一个名人在四月份自杀身亡，那么无论如何自杀率都会上升。所以你必须弄清楚增加的部分有多少是由于对自杀的接触增加导致的，有多少是自然增长。大约一年前有一篇综述说，名人的宣传对自杀率有轻微的影响，影响非常小。当你查看所有这些不同的研究时，有些人发现它有影响，有些人没有，你把它们放在一起看。可能存在轻微的传染效应。但我们看看“聚集”，这是不同的。现在，聚集是指你个人认识的人死于自杀。
So if a celebrity dies by suicide in April, well, there's going to be an increase in suicide rates anyways. So you have to figure out how much is the increase due to the increased exposure of the suicide versus the natural increase. There was a review about a year ago that says there's a slight impact of publicity of celebrities on suicide rates, a very small impact. When you look at all these different studies, someone which found it impacts some dent, you look at them all together. There might be a slight contagion effect. But we look at clusters, which is different. Now, clusters is when you know someone personally who's died from suicide.
所以，例如，在一些学校，突然有几名学生自杀，他们有时互相认识。这只是巧合吗？我的意思是，有时可能只是巧合。但一个人的自杀是否对其他人的自杀风险有某种影响？似乎确实有影响。你知道，认识一个死于自杀的人确实会增加一个人自己死于自杀的风险。
And so, for example, in some schools, there are all of a sudden several suicides of students in a school who sometimes they knew each other. And is this just a coincidence? I mean, sometimes it might be just a coincidence. But is there some kind of effect to the suicide of one person increase the risk? of suicides for other people. And it appears that there is an impact. You know, knowing someone who's died from suicide does increase a person's risk of dying from suicide themselves.
这取决于他们对那个人的了解程度，以及许多其他因素，但风险确实有轻微增加。现在，为什么会这样？现在，有些人说这可能是一种模仿效应。这可能是对暴力的习惯化。人们，认识一个死于自杀的人，可能会把它视为一种选择。还有关于公立学校应该如何公开回应的讨论
It depends on how well they knew the person, many other factors, but there is a slight increase in risk. Now, why is that? Now, some people say it might be a modeling effect. it might be habituation to violence. People, knowing someone who died from suicide, might see it as an option. There's also been discussions about how should public schools respond publicly
当一名学生死于自杀时。你如何纪念学生的生活而不美化它？所以美国自杀学协会制定了指导方针，说明如何做到这一点，以免它看起来美化它或增加其他学生自杀身亡的风险。有一种东西叫“社交网络理论”，它说我们的许多特质与我们亲近的人相似，最多有三度分隔。所以如果你认识一个死于自杀的人，你的风险会更高。如果你认识一个认识死于自杀的人的人，风险会稍微高一点。
when a student dies from suicide. How can you honor the student's life without glamorizing it? And so there's guidelines established by the, American Association of Suicidology on how to do that so that it doesn't appear to glamorize it or increase the risk of other students dying from suicide. There's something called social network theory which says that many of our traits are similar to those who are close to us, up to three degrees of separation. So if you know someone who dies from suicide, your risk is going to be higher. If you know someone who knew someone who died from suicide, it's going to be a little bit higher.
三度分隔会稍微高一点。除此之外，可能就没有影响了。但是是的，确实似乎存在聚集效应。现在自杀是否比过去更受关注？还是您认为凶杀案受到的关注更多？嗯，我认为对自杀的关注更多了，这是应该的。它在很大程度上被忽视了。现在，部分关注始于美国军队中极高的自杀率，但现在自杀率自1999年以来增加了30%。
Three degrees of separation is going to be a tiny bit higher. And beyond that, there's probably not an effect. But yeah, there does appear to be a cluster effect. Does it seem like suicide, the spotlight is on suicide more now today than it was in the past? Or do you think homicides get more attention? Well, I think there's more attention on suicide. as it should be. It's been neglected a great deal. Now, as part of the attention started because the high suicide rates in the United States military, but now it's a 30% increase in suicide since
所以它值得成为公众关注的焦点。这是一个非常被忽视的公共卫生领域。例如，在金门大桥，自大桥建成以来，已经有三起。我想是2000起自杀事件之类的。他们修建了一条自行车道，尽管在金门大桥骑自行车受伤的人数微乎其微。为了安全起见，在自行车道上花费了数百万美元。我不反对自行车道，但那是优先于在桥下安装一张网，这可以拯救人们。
1999. And so it deserves to be in the public spotlight. It's a very neglected area of public health. For example, in the Golden Gate Bridge, there has been three. I think 2,000 suicides or something like that since the bridge was constructed. They built a bicycle lane, even though the number of people being injured riding bicycles and the Golden Gate Bridge is minuscule. Spent millions of dollars on a bicycle lane for safety purposes. I'm not opposed to a bicycle lane, but that was a priority over putting a net underneath the bridge which would save people.
免于死于自杀，尽管死于自杀的人数远多于在金门大桥死于自行车事故的人数。这只是一个例子。你看看研究经费。自杀是美国的第10或第11大死因，与肺病、肾病相当，尽管肺病和肾病每种获得的联邦研究经费大约是自杀的20倍。所以我们在研究方面确实处于劣势，因为缺乏资金。它确实是一个非常严重的被忽视的公共卫生领域。我认为这与对患有精神疾病和尝试自杀的人的神话和偏见污名有关。
from dying from suicide, even though far more people died from suicide than died from bicycle accidents on the Golden Gate Bridge. And that's just one example. You look at funding for research. Suicide is the 10th or 11th leading cause of death in the United States, comparable to lung disease, kidney diseases, even though lung disease and kidney disease each receive about 20 times the amount of federal funding for research. than suicide does. So we are really disadvantaged in terms of research because of the lack of funding. It really is being a very serious neglected area of public health. And I think it has to do with myths and prejudice stigma against people who have mental illnesses and who attempt suicide.
是的，这正是我想问您的。您认为是因为污名吗？总的来说，随着讨论的增多，污名似乎确实正在减轻一点，但是，你知道，研究经费需要随着公众舆论的变化而跟上。绝对是这样。《监测》文章指出，研究自杀的心理学家仍然是一个相对较小的群体，因为历史上大多数研究是由在精神病学环境中与患者工作的精神科医生完成的。让心理学家研究自杀为什么至关重要？嗯，幸运的是，心理学家越来越多地参与到
Yeah, that's exactly what's going to ask you. Do you think it's because of the stigma? It does seem in general that the stigma might be lifting a little bit is the more it gets discussed, but, you know, that's the research dollars need to catch up with that with public opinion changing. Absolutely. The Monitor article stated that psychologists who studies suicide are still members of a relatively small group because historically most research was done by psychiatrists who work with patients in psychiatric settings. Why is it critical to have psychologists study suicide? Well, fortunately, psychologists are getting more involved in the study of
自杀的研究中，在我看来，研究质量非常出色。我的意思是，显然还有很多工作要做。但在过去几年里，研究是现象级的，并且具有非常现实的公共卫生意义。例如，治疗的有效性。我们现在知道，有，我们一直怀疑心理健康治疗将拯救那些死于自杀、有自杀风险的人的生命。但现在我们有证据真正毫无疑问地表明，你有克雷格·布莱恩和戴维·拉德关于认知行为疗法的研究，戴维·乔布斯关于自杀倾向的协作评估和管理，马歇尔·莱恩汉的辩证行为疗法，以及，你知道，
suicide and the quality of research is excellent in my opinion. I mean, obviously much more needs to be done. But in the last few years, the research is phenomenal and has very real public health implications. For example, efficacy of treatments. We now know that there are, we've always suspected that mental health treatment is going to save. lives of people who die from suicide, who at risk to die from suicide. But now we have evidence that really shows without a doubt that you have research by Craig Brian and David Rudd on cognitive behavior therapies, David Jobs on collaborative assessment and management of suicidality, Marshall Linnehan dialectical behavioral therapy, and, you know,
盖伊·戴蒙德的依恋疗法。我们有这些研究表明，是的，我们确实有有效的治疗方法。而且研究正在更多地研究自杀危机状态下发生的事情。你知道，雷蒙德·塔克、梅根·罗杰斯、托马斯·乔伊纳和伊戈尔·格连科关于自杀危机状态的一些非常好的研究，即一个人在尝试自杀前立即发生的事情。这在预防和治疗方面确实开启了很多事后检查。所以我对在这个领域工作的心理学家印象非常深刻。
Guy Diamond's attachment-based therapy. we have these studies that show, yeah, we really have effective treatments. And research is studying more on the phenomenon of what happens in the suicidal crisis state. You know, some really good research by Raymond Tucker and Megan Rogers and Thomas Joyner and Igor Gellenko on the suicide crisis state, what happens immediately before a person attempts suicide. This is really opening a lot of post-examination. as far as prevention and treatment are concerned. So I'm just so impressed by the psychologists who are working in this area.
我从这些研究中受益匪浅。很高兴知道这个领域有很多伟大的研究成果，这将帮助人们前进。我想谈谈给人们的一些实用建议。我们如何识别可能正在考虑自杀的人的迹象？嗯，这并不总是容易做到的。人们已经制定了这些警告信号列表。有时列表变得非常非常长。
I benefited a great deal from the research. That's wonderful to know that there's a lot of great research coming out in this field that will help people moving forward. And I want to talk to some more of the practical tips for people. How do we recognize the signs of someone who might be contemplating suicide? Well, it's not always easy to do. And there's been these lists of warning science that people have developed. And sometimes the lists become very, very long.
其中一个问题是它们变得太长，变得毫无用处，因为有太多的因素与自杀的关系微乎其微，以至于，嗯，我看到的一个列表。如果一个青少年对老师不尊重。你知道，那，好吧，青少年不尊重人是不好的。但那不是，他们不尊重人有很多不同的原因，自杀念头可能是其中之一，但只是众多原因中的一个。但如果你认为，哦，这个孩子不尊重人，他们一定是想自杀。你大部分时间都会错的，以至于这些警告列表因为，因为，你大部分时间都会错的。这些警告
And one of the problems is that they come so long, they become useless because there's so many factors that are so marginally related to suicide that, well, well, one list I see. if a teenager is disrespectful to a teacher. You know, that's, well, okay, this is not good that teenagers are disrespectful. But that's not, they're disrespectful for a lot of different reasons, of which suicidal thoughts might be one out of many, many, many. But if you go thinking, oh, this child is disrespectful, they must be suicidal. You're just going to be wrong. So much of the time that these warnings list because, because, you're just going to be wrong. so many much of the time that these warnings
列表变得毫无意义。但找出答案的最好方法之一就是直接问某人。或者你可以退后一步，问问他们整体情况如何？
list become meaningless. But one of the best things ways to find out is just ask someone. Or you can take a step back and just how are you doing overall?
你怎么样？如果你担心某人，专注于你与他们的关系。你知道，花时间和他们在一起。思考一下，比如在一个家庭中，父母和孩子，或者孩子和年长的父母。你怎么样？花时间和他们在一起，高质量的时间。现在，因为我提到的一些研究，
How are you doing? If you're concerned about someone, focus on your relationship with them. You know, spend time with them. thinking like in a family, a parent and a child or a child and an older parent. How are you doing? Spend time with them, quality of time. Now, because of some of the research I mentioned,
雷蒙德·塔克、梅根·罗杰斯和其他人，我们确实对人们在尝试自杀前所处的即时心理状态了解更多。确实有一些事情会发生，焦虑、失眠、易怒。我们提到了感知到的负担感、被困感、羞辱感。那些是，我们知道这些状态存在于大量最终自杀身亡的人中。所以这是我们最近进行的一些研究的实际应用之一。所以就干预而言，如果一个亲人是，你担心一个亲人，它可以是像您提到的那样，说一些关于你怎么样之类的话。
Raymond Tucker and Megan Rogers and others, we do know more about the immediate psychological states that people have before a suicide attempt. And there are some things that occur, agitation, insomnia, irritability. We mentioned perceivorismness, a sense of entrapment, humiliation. Those are, we know those states are present in a large number of people who eventually go on to die from suicide. So that's one of the practical applications of some of the recent research that we've had. So in terms of intervening, if a loved one is, you're worried about a loved one, it can be something like, as you mentioned, saying something about how are you doing, that sort of thing.
还有什么其他方法可以干预以确保某人的安全？嗯，我的意思是，如果他们目前有自杀倾向，你知道，现在，你知道，是的，有人你自杀吗？是的，我是。让他们接受治疗，并与治疗提供者合作，愿意成为治疗提供者的资产，以及他们正在做的事情。而且很难概括，因为有太多不同的，每个案例都是独特的。但尽你所能促进他们的整体福祉，并再次回到联系感，确保你有一个良好的关系。现在，家庭成员通常是非常善意的，他们需要在有帮助和过于家长式、过于控制之间取得平衡，人们有时会这样做。
What are other ways you can intervene to keep someone safe? Well, I mean, if they're currently suicidal, you know, right now, you know, yes, someone are you suicidal? Yes, I am. Get them into treatment and work with the treatment provider, be willing to be an accident. asset to the treatment provider and what they're doing. And it's hard to generalize because there's so many different, every case is unique. But doing what you can to promote their overall well-being and going back, once again, to the sense of connection, making sure that you have a good relationship. Now, family members usually are very well-intentioned, and they need to draw a balance between being helpful and being overly paternalistic, overly controlling, which sometimes people do.
当他们害怕某人有自杀倾向时，他们往往会变得专横、教条和咄咄逼人，动机可能是好的。但这实际上可能会让人们反感，而不是让他们感到更亲近。心理学家如何治疗有自杀倾向的患者？您在实践中使用什么基于研究的干预措施，或者您建议其他人使用什么？嗯，我提到了一些。而且，你知道，认知行为疗法、辩证行为疗法、协作评估、自杀管理。还有我们所谓的自杀管理策略。
When they're afraid someone is suicidal, they'll tend to be bossy and dogmatic and pushy and the motives might be good. but that actually can turn people off as opposed to making them feel closer. And how do psychologists treat suicidal patients? What research-informed interventions do you use in your practice or do you suggest others use? Well, I mentioned some of them. And, you know, cognitive behavior therapy, technological behavioral therapy, collaborative assessment, management, suicide. There's also what we call suicide management strategies.
但从广泛的问题来看，路易斯·卡斯顿·盖伊和克拉拉·希尔编辑的一本关于为什么有些治疗师比其他人更好的书非常好。其中一章说，好吧，真正好的治疗师做什么？其中之一是良好的关系。他们努力练习他们所做的事情。他们很谦虚。这真的很好，因为谦逊，客观地审视自己的能力，因为他们不怕反馈。他们引出反馈。
But looking at the broad question, there's a very good book edited by Louis Kaston Gay and Clara Hill on why some therapists are better than others. And one of the chapters there says, okay, what do really good therapists do? and one of them was like good relationships. They practice hard at what they do. They're humble. And this is really good because humility, ability to look at oneself objectively, because they're not afraid of feedback. They elicit feedback.
如果患者没有好转，他们想知道，他们会不遗余力地获得反馈。然后我们看看除了好的治疗之外，自杀患者有什么特别之处。克雷格·布莱恩最近有一篇非常好的文章，关于有效自杀治疗中的一些共同因素。现在，他正在研究军队中的治疗，但我认为这也适用于其他地方。
If a patient isn't doing better, they want to know about it, and they will go out of their way to get the feedback. And then we look at what is there specific about, suicidal patients other than good therapy in general. And there was a very nice article recently by Craig Bryan on some of the common factors in effective suicide treatments. Now, he was looking at treatments in the military, but I think this applies in other places as well.
其中之一是确保患者参与治疗，他们相信治疗并坚持治疗。你不能总是假设这一点。有时人们来的时候非常沮丧，以至于他们知道没有什么能帮助我，或者我不值得被拯救。获得他们的认同非常重要。教授特定的技能。人们处于巨大的情绪困扰中，给他们技能。哦，例如，失眠与自杀企图有很强的联系。
One of them was making sure that patients are engaged in treatment and they believe in treatment and follow through with treatment. You can't always assume that. Sometimes people come and so demoralize that they know nothing's going to help me or I'm not worth saving. That getting their buy-in is really important. Teaching specific skills. People are in a great deal of emotional distress and giving them skills. Oh, for example, insomnia has a very strong link with suicide attempts.
它极大地增加了某人尝试自杀的风险。如果所有其他事情，他们根本睡不好，有慢性失眠。知道这一点，能够，而且人们可以做一些事情。有睡眠卫生，有可以做的梦境排练来减少噩梦。有一些药物可以在短期内改善睡眠。所以知道这些东西，能够降低他们的情绪唤起，给他们技能很重要。然后另一个非常重要的，天真的心理治疗师会错过，但非常关键，那就是自杀管理，即能够提供具体的步骤，这样一个人就不太可能
It greatly increases the risk that someone is going to take. attempt suicide. If all the other things, they're not sleeping well at all, have chronic insomnia. And knowing that, being able, and there's things that people can do. There's sleep hygiene, there's a magical rehearsal that can be done to reduce nightmares. There's some medications that can be done in the short term to improve sleep. So knowing that stuff, being able to get their emotional arousal down, giving them skills is important. And then another very important one that a naive psychotherapist miss, but it's very crucial, and that is suicide management, as being able to give concrete steps so a person is less
尝试自杀，而不是在短期内。你想在短期内保证他们的安全。所以心理治疗有机会发挥作用。这是一件非常重要的事情。幸运的是，关于自杀管理项目已经有一些非常好的研究，例如格雷格·布朗和芭芭拉·斯坦利关于一些安全管理策略的研究，以及其他研究人员对此所做的工作，这确实提供了非常具体的步骤，这些步骤已被证明可以帮助人们降低自杀风险。你知道，有一项研究是在询问退伍军人时做的，什么让你没有自杀？
likely to attempt suicide than in the short term. You want to keep them safe in the short term. So the psychotherapy has a chance to work. And that's a very important thing to do. And fortunately, there's been some very good research on suicide management programs, such as Greg Brown and Barbara Stanley on some safety management strategies and some other researchers have done work on that, that really gives very concrete steps on things which have been in parisand. verified to help people reduce the risk of suicide. You know, there's one study that was done when asked veterans, what kept you from killing yourself?
他们给出的第一个原因，我的意思是，他们给出了许多不同的原因，但最常见的一个是我的心理治疗师关心我。哇。这确实说明了很多问题。确实。你想建立一种关系。你希望在第一次会议结束时，你希望患者认为，这个心理治疗师真的很关心我。
And the number one reason they gave, I mean, they gave many different reasons, but the most common one was my psychotherapist cared about me. Wow. And that certainly does say a lot. It does. You want to build a relationship. you want at the end of the first session, you want the patient to think, this psychotherapist really cares about me.
而且你也希望他们有机会讲述他们的故事。现在，治疗方面的进展之一，对于没有与自杀患者工作经验的人来说，可能会有一种恐惧，他们可能会危言耸听，他们可能会变得过度控制。哦，你必须去医院。或者我必须告诉你家人。我不在乎你怎么想。无论你怎么想，我都要告诉你家人。过度控制，专横。
And you also want them to have a chance to tell their story. Now, one of the advances in treatment, with people who are not experienced working with suicidal patients, there might be a fear, they might be alarmist, they might become over-controlling. Oh, you got to go to the hospital. Or I have to tell you family members. I don't care what you think. I'm going to tell your family members regardless of what you think. Over-controlling, bossy.
你同时也希望他们有机会讲述自己的故事。现在，治疗方面的进展之一是，对于那些在处理自杀倾向患者方面缺乏经验的人来说，他们可能会感到恐惧，可能会危言耸听，也可能会变得过度控制。哦，你必须去医院。或者我必须告诉你的家人。我不管你怎么想。不管你怎么想，我都要告诉你的家人。过度控制，专横跋扈。
And that can turn people off very quickly. But it's much better to listen to them. Instead of arguing with them, you should live. Here's the reasons you should live. For every reason you give, they're going to tell you two reasons why they shouldn't live. You're never going to win that argument. But it's much better to. to give them experience of having someone listen to you.
这会很快让人反感。但倾听他们要好得多。与其和他们争论你应该活下去，列举你应该活下去的理由，不如倾听。你每给出一个理由，他们就会告诉你两个不该活下去的理由。你永远赢不了那场争论。但给他们一种被人倾听的体验要好得多。
You have the experience of a human connection. So you're not arguing with them, but you're giving them a meaningful human experience that intrinsically makes life worth living. And that's better than any argument you could ever give. For people who've experienced a loss of a loved one by suicide, how do they best cope in the aftermath? Oh, that's very difficult. The pain of people who suffer afterwards is very great.
你让他们体验到人与人之间的联系。所以你不是在和他们争论，而是给他们一种有意义的人际体验，这从本质上让生命变得值得活下去。这比你所能给出的任何论点都要好。对于那些经历过亲人自杀离世的人来说，事后他们该如何最好地应对呢？哦，那非常困难。事后遭受痛苦的人们所承受的痛苦是非常巨大的。
There was a study done which looked at families of veterans who had a member die from suicide and those who died from natural causes or from combat. And when a family member died from suicide, the adjustment was far worse. And you think about why is that? Well, one of which is shame, guilt, stigma. And people ask themselves, why didn't I pick up on it? Well, what could I have done differently? What's wrong with me as a spouse? I didn't pick up on this.
有一项研究调查了退伍军人家庭，其中一些成员死于自杀，另一些死于自然原因或战斗。当家庭成员死于自杀时，家人的适应情况要糟糕得多。你可能会想，为什么会这样？嗯，其中一个原因是羞耻感、内疚感和污名化。人们会问自己，为什么我没有察觉到？我本可以做些什么不同的事情？作为配偶，我有什么问题吗？我竟然没有察觉到这一点。
And the reaction of others is often worse. And people described where they had friends for years and then they just dropped them. Or they have people who would never bring it up. You know, there you are consumed by grief. the most important thing in your life and people aren't talking about it. If you do bring it up, they change the subject.
而他人的反应往往更糟糕。人们描述说，他们有相处多年的朋友，结果对方却疏远了他们。或者有些人永远不会提起这件事。你知道，你沉浸在悲痛之中，这是你生命中最重要的事情，而人们却对此只字不提。如果你主动提起，他们就会转移话题。
So the reaction of others is very important in the post post-death adjustment. So how do you go on? You just go on like you would otherwise you rebuild your life. And if possible,
因此，他人的反应在丧亲后的适应过程中非常重要。那么你该如何继续生活呢？你就像往常一样继续生活，重建你的生活。如果可能的话，
you connect with other survivors who've gone through a very similar experiences. And the American Association of Suicidology does have survivor groups that, opportunities for people to connect with others when there's been a loved one who died from suicide. Yeah, those are great resources for people. Is there any advice for a long-term impact on the surviving family members and friends? I mean, does it change, you know, right after the event versus a year or two later or five? years later?
你可以与其他经历过类似遭遇的幸存者建立联系。美国自杀学协会确实有幸存者小组，为那些有亲人死于自杀的人提供与他人联系的机会。是的，这些对人们来说是非常好的资源。对于幸存的家庭成员和朋友的长期影响，有什么建议吗？我的意思是，事件发生后立即的情况与一两年后或五年后相比，会有所改变吗？
You know, I don't know. You know, you, the general trend is after trauma, people move to a baseline, but I don't know the long-term data on that. Now, we do know that statistically, you know, we talked about the cluster effect. You know, statistically when a family member dies from suicide, increases the suicide risk of everyone in the family. Now, it's even more of an effect than with a friend. It may be that there are common biological factors that predispose a person to a mental illness.
你知道，我不知道。你知道，总的趋势是创伤过后，人们会回到基准线，但我不知道这方面的长期数据。现在，我们确实知道从统计学上讲，我们谈到了集群效应。你知道，从统计学上讲，当一名家庭成员死于自杀时，会增加家庭中每个人的自杀风险。现在，这种影响甚至比朋友自杀的影响更大。这可能是因为存在共同的生物学因素，使人容易患上精神疾病。
It might be a similar stressful environment. We don't know. But obviously, most family members don't go on to die from suicide themselves. Other than that, I don't know much about the long-term adjustment. families. Well, thank you so much for joining us, Dr. Knapp. It's been a really wonderful conversation, very insightful, very informative. Well, thank you. I appreciate it. The Monitor story on suicide published online on July 1st. You can read it by visiting APA's website at APA.org slash monitor. And a reminder to all of our listeners who want to hear from you, you can email me your comments and
这可能是一种相似的压力环境。我们不知道。但显然，大多数家庭成员并不会因此而自杀。除此之外，我不太了解家庭的长期适应情况。好的，非常感谢您加入我们，纳普博士。这是一次非常精彩的谈话，非常有见地，信息量很大。好的，谢谢。我很感激。关于自杀的《观察家》报道于7月1日在线发布。您可以访问美国心理学会网站 APA.org/monitor 阅读。提醒所有想听到你们声音的听众，你们可以通过电子邮件将评论发送给我，
ideas at K-Luna at APA.org. That's K-L-U-N-A-A-A-A-R. Also, please consider giving us a rating in iTunes, we'd really appreciate it. Speaking of Psychology is part of the APA podcast network, which includes other great podcasts, such as APA journals, dialogue about new psychological research and progress notes about the practice of psychology. You can find all of our podcasts on iTunes, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. You can also go to our website speakingof psychology.org to listen to more episodes. I'm Caitlin Luna with the American Psychological Association. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
地址是 K-Luna@APA.org。那是 K-L-U-N-A@APA.org。另外，请考虑在 iTunes 上给我们评分，我们将不胜感激。《心理学谈话》是美国心理学会播客网络的一部分，该网络还包括其他优秀的播客，例如《美国心理学会期刊》，探讨新的心理学研究，以及《进度记录》，探讨心理学实践。您可以在 iTunes、Stitcher 或任何您获取播客的地方找到我们所有的播客。您也可以访问我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 收听更多剧集。我是美国心理学会的凯特琳·卢纳。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。